hi I'm Matt Welch for reason TV I'm here
in Tampa at the republican national
convention we're here on day 1 on radio
row where 15,000 journalists are trying
to figure out if there's any stories to
cover we think there's three worth
watching this week story number one
what's going to happen the Ron Paul
movement within the Republican Party and
is it likely to stay there and is it
likely to vote Republican there is a
Paul festival over the weekend where the
man who got upwards of eleven percent of
the vote in the primary season give a
rip roarin speech against blowback and
against the foreign policy of the
Republican Party in fact how the
Republican Party deals with this rump
faction is going to be a source of much
conflict and has been already story
number two will the real Paul Ryan be
allowed to stand up whether or not he
can the vice presidential pick is
supposed to leave one of the great wonks
of Washington and a man who's finally
serious enough to talk about and tackle
entitlement reform which this country so
desperately needs yet the presidential
nominee mitt romney has proven to be
decidedly not very serious or wonky when
it comes to things like cutting and
reforming Medicare so is this not to
fiscal conservatism as good as it is
likely to get the story will be
following here finally story number
three what's going to happen to social
conservatives and the whole idea that
the government should leave us the hell
alone not just an economic matters but
in personal matters the week before the
convention big hubbub about various
comments about abortion and rape and now
this week there's going to be a lot of
discussion about immigration
highlighting the fact perhaps that
Romney is no george w bush when it comes
to treating people who came here to
better their lives but broke American
law while doing it seeing how these
stories play out the background of 2012
is going to tell us a lot about whether
Mitt Romney and Paul Ryan are going to
win but more importantly whether the
Republican Party is going to get serious
at long last about embracing freedom for
reason TV I am Matt Welch